then we're gonna begin with the second
round of the Democratic presidential
debates they featured a string of
attacks on frontrunner Jill Biden the
former vice president had to repeatedly
defend his long record on everything
from health care to immigration to
criminal justice this followed a debate
in June when Kamala Harris gained ground
by attacking Biden at O'Keefe is in
Detroit where he covered last night's
faceoff and how did Biden respond this
time well Anthony it was a stronger
defense of his record than last month
but it was by no means smooth at the
beginning of the night Joe Biden shook
hands with Kamala Harris and was hurt to
say go easy on me kid but nobody on
stage did mr. vice president you want to
be President United States you need to
be able to answer the tough questions
the house was set on fire and you
claimed responsibility for those laws
for the second time former Vice
President Joe Biden found himself under
fire from the rest of the Democratic
field if you cross the border illegally
you should be able to be sent back it's
a crime it looks like one of us has
learned the lessons of the past and one
of us hasn't but this time Biden saw it
coming so this idea is a bunch of
malarkey and took on California senator
Kamala Harris on health care the
Senators had several plans so far and
any time someone tells you to get
something good in ten years you should
wonder why it takes ten years if you
notice there's no talk about the fact
that the plan in ten years will cost
three trillion dollars the reality is
that our plan will bring health care to
all Americans under a medicare-for-all
system under your plan status quo you do
nothing to hold the insurance companies
to task I have the only plan that limits
the ability of insurance companies to
charge unreasonable prices flatout
Harris herself became a bigger target
forced to defend her past record as
California's Attorney General
she put over 1,500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana I did the work of
significantly reforming the criminal
justice system of a state of 40 million
people which became a national model for
the work that needs to be done and I
I'm proud of that work but it was
Biden's long record that got the most
attention even when he tried to pivot
why did you announce in the first day a
zero tolerance policy of stop and frisk
and hire Rudy Giuliani's guy in 2007
when I was trying to get rid of the
crack cocaine mr. vice president there's
a saying in my community you're dipping
into kool-aid and you don't even know
the flavor and see the reforms that we
put in place you were trying to shift
the view from what you created and Biden
tried to turn the attacks back toward
president Trump eight more years of
Donald Trump will change America in a
fundamental way America we know will no
longer exist
so when Democrats meet again in
September we expect to see fewer
candidates on stage because of stricter
qualification rules by then candidate
will have had to have found donations
from at least 130,000 people across the
country and be earning at least 2% in at
least four polls so far only seven of
the two dozen candidates have qualified
they've got until the end of August to
make it Anthony
one month head thank you